Sáng nay ngừng năm tặng 1 năm hành hình khu trông an bài sống tại sế phản bài sôn,
xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tâm biến chính, buộc khu hồ đúng sơn, tình thinh hóa,
được hiện sế tại bài mài sấu hát khu bụt sau chiến tâm,
lưu tông chính Quốc lộ bụn vi bẩy bây, cứ ngưu sơn, sau vang, khi đến diễn phận sát thỏng học,
tinh hóa, đã và trạm buổi sế độ kéo bài mài sấu hát khu bụt sau khu mà,
xói tài sế phản bình tính, xin nămu nghìn chính trâm chính bây tư, buộc sát thinh thỏng tình thinh hóa,
được hiện đi theo hướng ngược lại.
Hầu quà sẽ đầu kéo đã lực ngang, đẹ chúng sế còn bài mài sấu hà bài chính bài hình xế,
xói tài sế lửa vê hát, xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tâm biệt tình thinh hóa,
được hiện xế còn biến sạc, tài sế hát tử vong tại chỗ, bông ở đi cùng vị thương,
mấy nguyện cụ tăng đăng được đưu trả.